welcome to episode 64 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with shane
gillis and matt mccusker
of matt and shane's secret podcast two
comedians
one more well-known from being kicked
off of snl before he got on stage
i really like speaking to comedians so
here they are i hope you enjoy this
episode
hit subscribe if you do every sunday and
wednesday i release episodes
this episode is brought to you by true
local the company that i buy my meat
from
and absolutely superb meat delivery
service
go to trulocal.ca and order a custom box
enter code mp for free steaks their lamb
is great their steaks are great their
wild salmon is great
they also have chicken pork sausages and
some vegetables too
i've used them for about two and a half
years now i get a box every two weeks on
subscription
tru local.ca code mp so they know where
you came from
and here's shane and matt
[Music]
shane and matt welcome to my podcast hey
hey thanks for having us
yeah i'm i'm a tad nervous about this
one uh we got introduced through a
mutual friend and i've been trying to
speak with more comedians because
you guys are entertaining and during
covid we need all the entertainment we
can get
and i've been i talked to health people
or comedians hopefully so that's why you
guys are on
can we start off by both of you giving a
bit of a background about who you are
and what it is that you do
matt go ahead first brother um well i'm
a
i'm a deeply spiritual man i i used to
sell marijuana for a long time and i
knocked that off
and then i pursued comedy and now i uh
i just do a podcast and i have a couple
other things going on so
that's it i do a comedy podcast and i
have a kid
and you know i don't really introduce
myself that much so it makes me kind of
nervous but he's been divorced
i've been divorced i'm a divorcee but
i'm remarried so yeah i've had
i've had a pretty tumultuous life yeah
dude you're leaving out you gotta you've
got a tail to tell it's it's not i can't
i can't put it in a little cat man it's
true
so yeah i'm just i'm as a dude man i've
done a lot of stuff
you know what dude don't come on here
and be a freaking jerk
all right uh i'm also
deeply spiritual i uh i am no i
i just got i don't know i do stand up i
do stand up comedy that's the only thing
i really
care about at all and uh that's it
and then i do a podcast me and matt have
a podcast and uh we got cancelled
yeah so i wanna i wanna get into that we
got canceled a little bit
oh yeah for the listeners out there you
may know me from uh
the guy who was hired by saturday night
live for like 10 minutes
yeah yeah shane lost potentially
millions and i almost got kicked out of
graduate school so
yeah that was what happened
you almost got kicked out of graduate
school yeah i was going for social work
so they weren't too uh
fond of i had a double life going on and
they found out what i was really up to
and they were not happy yeah but
oh yeah social work's not the place to
be for that no it's not
they don't like that kind of stuff they
don't like joshing around at all
no no okay so i don't know
i don't know i did a i do a background
research obviously on people who i have
on
and one of the ways i do that is i ask
my audience questions
what would you ask these guys and that
usually i don't usually use very many of
those questions but it gives
me kind of a background information on
the people i'm talking to
and the questions people ask to you guys
made
no sense like all of them they were all
inside jokes and i was just like
oh my god so i was looking at these this
morning and i was like
okay we'll see we'll see how this goes
but i'm going to ask you a few of those
sure start off and then we'll get into
other things
so um how one person said
ask about the dick sirens
i don't even know i know i remember the
dick sirens what is that
the sirens on the rocks the dongs trying
to
trying to get you off your voice oh yeah
for sure oh okay yeah yeah
i think it was when i was trying to quit
porn yeah i think we're talking about
the science
kind of when you're you know like the i
think it was what is it ulesses yeah
julie essie's or whatever his name is
now he's tied himself to the
master of the ship to avoid the science
unless he's yeah yes
yeah that's definitely coming from
social work
anyway what so what is this what's this
background what's this background
quitting porn
did you end up quitting porn did that
make a difference i did a podcast with a
anti-porn person and a pro porn person
that's our product
yes well i don't have any like bones to
pick with other people doing it i just
feel like owners to pick
come on man come on dude
come on baby that's why i want you guys
on the podcast great jokes
comments like that yeah well no i just
think it was uh
i don't have like a a moral conundrum or
whatever with porn it's just like
i feel like it's wasted energy and
almost after i like stop watching porn i
feel like i just like
kissed a blow up doll and i'm like ah i
come too and i'm just like
uh i gotta stop this which is weird
cause when i stop watching porn i uh
have to get tissues just roll over and
go
take a nap yeah me and shane are very
like yin yang
i'm very yin yeah obviously shane's very
yang i'm more young
kind of like you know merlin arthur
situation i'm obviously merlin but yeah
yeah i'm more of an arthrotype
yeah so i don't know that that reference
king arthur and merlin the wizard oh god
okay
yeah yeah i don't know what the [ __ ] i
was talking about you heard them
referred to so casually
arthur and merlin but the uh but no that
was kind of my whole you know i
especially within a relationship i'm
married and it's like you know when you
tank a marriage
once you the second one hopefully if
you're you know
actively trying to be in a good marriage
you're like well let me not [ __ ] this
one up
so i'm just pulling out all the stops
that's why it's like all right i'm not
doing porn
yeah but that's a risk dude you can't be
pulling out all the stops you're gonna
you're gonna blow yourself out
especially trying not to
crumb at night no dude once you have
once you reproduce man it's like you
know it like it kind of
drops off a little bit i like my
experience i like thinking that people
are coming to this podcast to listen to
michaela speak and like oh it's like oh
this will be a nice like
learning experience it's just us talking
about
you can't cram at night true i don't
even know what that word
okay i get that word you know what it is
like i
can pick it up from keeping the
surrounding material
so what kind of i i saw you put that out
like what kind of questions you have for
these guys and i went oh
don't ask i know don't ask them yeah it
was a mistake what else
and i read them all too what else are
they giving ah i have
i have uh which one is more salt life
i'm more so i'm the most i'm very salt
life
and what is that just salty like is that
that's just the slang salt i'm
like this is so far beyond me no it's
just i'm just about that salt life baby
yeah down down in a down in america way
they have this
brand called salt life it's about like
people who like go to the beach and like
basically people who try to like
rationalize alcoholism between
being like oh i love the beach so much
have this hashtag they can put on their
truck that has like dui dents in it that
says salt life
we've argued we've argued before about
who's more salt life
i'm clearly more solid if matt thinks
doing dope and pot
is uh more salt life but it's actually
about drinking light beers and pissing
in the sand
but yeah i know
that's okay no need to open the ceo
you're definitely going to trash this
episode the ceo
of salt life got indicted i think for
murdering a teenage girl so
if you want to bring like uh yeah i
think he got in trouble jesus
at least he got at least it was alleged
and apparently from
what i saw it seemed like they had a
decent case against him i think i can
safely say that
so that was kind of a that was kind of a
bummer to find out we had we had kind of
talked about salt life extensively and
then that guy went and i think murdered
a teenager
so that's not good yeah that that does
that makes it a little bit less funny
stock price that area i think matt's a
little more solid for me
[Laughter]
i'm regular salt life yeah right
so to answer your question i would say
i'm more assault life
all right have you guys been how long
have you guys been doing your podcast
for
how long have you guys known each other
is this since college man no
but we uh how long have you been doing
the podcast for i honestly don't know i
think it's been
four years four years uh we started
right when trump got elect we did it for
trump
yeah trump got elected like right as we
started doing it
uh people who are bad at comedy just
started like spazzing on everybody and
being like you guys should all
you know adopt a wildly new political
belief system and we're like uh we're
gonna do comedy because you know people
are booking us and stuff
like anti-trump yeah oh yeah everybody
in comedies
was very anti-trump at the and look i
don't care at all about trump but
i care about comedy so it was annoying
for like
we just sat there and watched everyone
like all our friends like kind of turn
on us
and say like we were nazis yeah they
started to racially audit the
makeup of shows so people started like
going around if you were doing shows
they started like hitting you out with
like a little receipt being like well we
counted
uh only one black guy and no gay people
so
you know we're bringing this year to and
it was it was just like it was just
weird no
oh yeah it was there was a spreadsheet
that went around it was infamous and
like and if you were to be like this is
crazy people would be like yeah
you're you're a nazi and it's like i
just think it's kind of screwed up
if you're going into a place and you're
counting how many black people are in
there then
that doesn't make the people well i i do
do that
[Laughter]
mentally though and then you don't tell
anyone and then you feel shame that you
counted them yeah you don't make a
spreadsheet man it was it was just like
you know that was what we were up
against and we met
i guess just four years ago we were both
we were doing a comedy show above an ice
cream parlor this was before
this is the season this was like six
years ago yeah yeah this is a while ago
so we met
and uh so i i like at that
year i remember i was like riding high i
had one philly's funniest and i'm like
i'm in my head i'm like i'm the man i'm
the best in philadelphia and then i saw
shane came down from he was in the in
the hills in central pa
i'm a hillman and i watched him come
down he just was killing it and i was
like god damn this dude's funny
[ __ ] and i was like damn and uh in my
head i was like am i
philly's funniest anymore i didn't know
that's sweet and then
and then after the show we met obviously
hit it off pretty well i think he showed
me a video of a guy getting eaten by a
tiger on his phone
and i showed him a video of a guy
jumping off of a roof and landing on his
back
and then we from then we just clicked up
yeah
we both we forged our bond by witnessing
death
together we both showed no fear or
weakness we stared death in the eyes on
our phones
in an ice cream parlor and that's how
the podcast was born that's how the
friendship was because
the friendship was born then we lived
together and
uh you know
but then we started eyebrows raising for
people listening on audio
i've broken multiple times we were adult
men living together with other adult it
was a commune of
losers complete losers
and then uh we just made a podcast in
our living room and
uh at first yeah all of a sudden like we
did it for ourselves like me and matt
just thought it was funny to like mess
with
we did like prank calls and like just
tried to make each other laugh and then
after a while like a bunch of people
once we started getting compliments it
was like oh [ __ ] this is actually like
something we can really do it was cool
is that is that what you guys have been
focused on during covid considering the
fact that
touring is dead i've been touring
yeah have you where uh
you can go to like everywhere else in
the country
other than the northeast yeah texas was
like i went down to texas with him it
was business as usual was 200 people oh
that's crazy
really yeah it was a blast they don't
have do they make you social distance or
it's like a third capacity or anything
or do they just say they're doing that
uh i'm not gonna name the club but yes
they were like we're at a third capacity
yeah it was just shoulder to shoulder it
was crazy
there was i think there was one person
that had a mask on the entire audience
yeah we and we chastised them for being
cowards
but no it was uh it was fun it was fun i
mean dude honestly it's a
i think it's good i think it's good to
tour and do you know comedy right now
but
to answer the question yeah it's like i
think that's been kind of the main focus
is like
just doing the podcast uh shane's shane
is more
he likes doing standing up more than me
i think he's better at it and i kind of
have a
wide array of interest so i kind of do a
bunch of stuff
so was that a compliment or an insult
that's a that's a compliment dude yeah
he's very easy
he's unidirectionally focused on
stanford you know he's really good at it
i'm kind of too
uh actually i took your dad's
personality test and i i have a
out of i think it's scored out of 100 my
conscientiousness is at
six so yeah yeah so that's not
it's not ideal that is tough really
thanks for the old kid
what do you think mine's at yours is
high dude i think i don't even know what
it is
exactly so here's the problem just
conscientiousness is like your ability
to follow through with tasks be on time
keep things clean
how likely you are to work you should
basically don't show your dad my room
[Laughter]
no i have i have 88 i have 88 openness
and i have
six conscientiousness so giving it your
agreeableness like
mid mid to low i think you're pretty
excited zero
i scored zero on agreeableness damn that
politeness not compassion they split it
into
politeness and compassion i scored zero
on politeness
that's pretty tight actually you seem
pretty polite
well maybe yes maybe it's one yes
i'm com like i don't like to hurt people
for absolutely no reason but if
somebody's in the wrong i don't mind
pointing it out even if they're
an authoritative or an authority figure
yeah i don't know i kind of do that or
sometimes i just won't do that for like
years and just deal with it
so i kind of go i see i don't do that
yeah i'll sit on a thing for a while and
then just spaz that's kind of my that's
my move
just wait it's like well you [ __ ]
moving they're like it was like two
years ago i'm like
yeah whatever
so okay okay 1777 life
76 yeah what the hell's 1777 what's
happening
that was what the person asked i don't
know yeah these are just
these are people just messing around
that doesn't even make sense we used to
talk about being
trying to make me look dumb that's kind
of i think that might be the effect this
podcast has on everybody
if you like listen to it long enough you
just become dumb yeah it's it's a cancer
yeah it's been described as destroys
everything it touches
what did someone described it as a uh
i'm trying to think
it was a was it did they call you an
alcoholic or a bully i know they called
me a schizophrenic
i'm definitely yeah that's fair yeah
they're like it's like an alcoholic
bully and a schizophrenic friend
talking for an hour you know i think
that's pretty fair it's actually pretty
close
every week i'm like i gotta turn things
around man i'm hungover
yeah you guys do video too or is it
audio video
we do a youtube okay okay good and has
that picked up
like do you get more video than audio
listeners yeah actually i think we do
yeah i think it's probably 50 50.
yeah i think the video started to creep
up it was yeah so we do
the video it went pretty well we didn't
do video forever uh
we did one video episode actually i
believe oh yeah and then that was the
stuff that was the stuff they got their
hands on and
canceled old chain with and then uh we
went in the back into like the you know
just audio
and then we we stepped back out and did
some youtube stuff so
so the podcast is what got shane kicked
off of snl
yes yes big time
okay yeah it was so what what happened
what happened there
were you just brought into a room and
they asked you if you would repent and
you said no
and then they fired you like what
happened well they
and there was a lot of people at nbc
that were like very like you need to
repent
right now and then there were other
people that were very like understanding
and cool about it and they were like
we get it we know that's not who you are
but you have
like you have to say something in order
for us to keep this alive to see if we
can get you on
to the show so yeah they handed me
like a the night that it broke the news
broke so i got announced on snl and then
within six hours i was getting canceled
like right away and uh
which is pretty funny but uh it was like
as soon as i was in the public eye
people were like get him out
get rid of this guy uh
but yeah they sent me like a a quote
like here's what you need to tweet out
say this say what i said was inexcusable
i'm terribly sorry
all this stuff and it was like well it's
not it's not inexcusable
and if i say that what i said here was
in fact
wrong and bad literally everything i've
ever said
was in the same tone i'm joking
so and i and i i what you said there
earlier about like i don't want to hurt
anybody of course i don't want to hurt
anybody
you know like so when i found out what i
said affected people like
i think there were some people being
honest that it did hurt them to read
those words and to hear those words
and i do i was sorry about that like i
don't want to hurt anybody with this
but i was just goofing yeah that's a
distinction man
that's the weirdest thing when people
read that stuff and they're just like
they just
jump to the wildest conclusion that it's
like oh my god this person
like as if i mean the situation was
painted as if we were like
two like korean war vets being like
asians oh yeah yeah it was just
it was crazy i was reading it being like
this is insane if you've actually
watched this it would be like
very hard to reach second it'd be very
crazy to think there was that many
people being hey it was really funny
like
it's weird to think that how many people
would tune into like two 30 year old men
being like in another thing i don't like
it it's like yeah it's crazy it's
insanity but you know that's kind of
what people are going for right now yeah
it's it's tricky too because
in order to be funny you kind of have to
walk the line between
verging on extremely inappropriate right
so if you're going to be a comedian then
it's going to be nearly impossible to
continue to be funny without
occasionally stepping you know over the
line or
not being funny by being too far from
the line but
it's like how do you continue to do
comedy if
there's so much risk to your careers
like what um what was the fallout from
from that oh i mean it was
it's like also i want to say this about
that
like the way we speak like when somebody
asks you about 1776
like it's almost all irony we're joking
we're sitting here ironically being like
they better not take our guns neither of
us have a gun
like we're joking you have a shotgun now
yeah my dad gave it to me
legal transfer father son sick but i
don't really think just in case
anybody listening cares yeah yeah i'll
never touch it
i carried a gun once my wife's actually
really good trained with guns and stuff
and
we went shooting i i dropped the gun in
the parking lot and you know that's
that's been my gun
yeah that's not great no that's why um
but the fallout was like i mean
even and also to go back to like when
they tell you to repent
and they're like you have to throw
yourself to the mob
and say sorry it's like first off
they're never going to accept your
apology
ever i could have said the most
well-thought-out
well-written tweet and they're going to
be like
fu no matter what they'd be like [ __ ]
this guy um
and there's also people that like care
about
comedy and i hate to be one of those
guys that's like i i do love this
like art form you know i hate to call it
an art form
but there's you have to have integrity
and you have to be like
no i can't i can't say sorry for this
like i can't there's too many people i
respect that would
that would uh hate me for that
including probably myself it's also it's
like taking when people know they didn't
do something they take like a guilty
plea just to reduce the sentence it's
like you know
understandable if you're facing like
actually 10 years in prison but it's
like
yeah it's just [ __ ] it's like
they're you know and i that was
something when i especially when i saw
you do that of just being like you know
using that opportunity just drop a i
thought it was a pretty wicked joke
in the tweet being like i was more of a
whatever like mad tv guy or whatever
yeah
it's like dude that's the whole point of
the job and like you know it
looks like i've done it better i could
have made it funnier but it was dude
there's
so much pressure i was so hot dude yeah
and i took it so seriously because it
was it was very serious i mean
the whole world it felt like was like
this guy's a piece of [ __ ]
and uh yeah thankfully i have friends
that were
you know like no you're not so that was
nice
yeah i talk a bit about on the podcast
about people who've gone through
like you got it hit pretty hard but
people have gone through experiences
where
everyone online suddenly hates them and
we are not like as people we're not
built for that amount of scrutiny and
hatred even though it's like people
online although
you had it in real life too right but
we're not we're not
made for that amount of stress so it
kills like it's
it's not it actually does kill people um
i had somebody reached out to me and
they got cancelled and it was kind of
small they were in like a hospital
institution
and they said something inappropriate
and they got cancelled online and they
didn't even have an audience and they
ended up killing themselves
so like it's not it's not casual it
really does it's really hard on people
and
you see it happen to celebrities and
you're like yeah well they can handle it
but
it hurts it's hard no it does and it's
uh it's i'm only like now coming to
terms with it it's been like almost two
years
and it's like it's been like a year and
a half and it's been like uh
there was definitely trauma there's like
i
there's like it [ __ ] you up it does
well it's also crazy too like the
large newspapers who you know will carry
these things out like
you know just not even thinking about it
they're obsessed with this idea of
inequity and lack of power and
inequality and it's like
they can literally write whatever they
want about anybody and you couldn't go
on and be like well actually there's no
you can't do it it's just it's [ __ ]
it's total [ __ ] and it's like you
know
hopefully more people will just stop
taking it seriously because it literally
i was reading the economist
yesterday and one of the main articles
was like well what is
china is what china is doing to the
uyghurs is that really genocide though i
don't think it is and we should be
careful how we phrase that we don't want
to mess up our trade with our ally and
it's like
who wrote this who was there like well
we don't want to mess up our trade with
china you know it's like
it's crazy it's [ __ ] it's i believe
it's paid for and it's written by people
who just don't have like
normal people best interest at heart and
it's it's nonsense dude and it's it's
crazy what you can do they also have no
problem
just totally misquoting you like uh oh
yeah
just totally misquoting like there was
there's one and it was in like
time it wasn't like time they they
quoted me and matt did a show in philly
where
you made fun of people behind their
backs on a screen so there was a screen
where there was a group text where
whoever was on stage was getting made
fun of
and everybody in the audience could see
the group text and uh besides the
comedian performing besides the
community performing so you would say
like the worst things possible because
it was also anonymous the group text
so people were saying like really messed
up things and then this lady
from uh a philadelphia magazine
interviewed us after and i said
uh we're learning that you can make fun
of asian people
and nobody has a problem with it which
and then the rest of the quote is which
is very hypocritical
but when they quoted me all they said
was
you can make fun of asian people and
that was in like time
magazine and it's like you guys you
deliberately left out the rest of the
quote
i had you guys probably don't know about
this but a couple of weeks ago
london times sunday times um published
a front cover story about my dad and
i did half of the interview uh because
he's been going through some
seriously like life-threatening health
problems
and i did half the interview to cover
the health aspect
and they just half of the article
which was the front cover of the sunny
times was just
[ __ ] on me yeah fortunately yeah it
was
horrible and i was like i can't if it
was like
daily mail or something then that's one
thing but this is like
this used to be a legitimate news source
it's certainly not anymore um but i
ended up making a video that kind of i'd
recorded the interview
so i was like this is what they wrote
this is what we actually said
um and that ended up very popular
luckily so at least for some people if
you have a platform you can
and you're really lucky about it you can
kind of hit back
but i think journalists used to be super
protected because they were uncovering
stories about corporations and they
needed
the protection so they wouldn't get like
killed from these corporations and now
it's completely turned around and they
can just
isolate individuals and just destroy
their lives without even thinking about
it it's not
a good setup but i think people are kind
of understanding what
mainstream media is like now because the
articles are getting so ridiculous like
you have to
they're treating people like morons
they're like ah they'll believe this
yeah i mean i actually saw like i think
i saw the first right before we did this
i watched like 20 minutes of that and
it was funny too to see that late it was
a lady who had written it too
she started taking like shots at your
like physical she like
documented your physical the color of
your hair and how it changed from one
year to year and it's like
i wonder how much of that was just girl
beef because she might have just been
like how
how not not to be a jerk but how old was
that as lady beef dude how old was
actually right
i think she was 35 or 40.
yeah she's writing jealous witch years
yeah man that's a tough time and she's
almost
she was like dad's a nazi and other did
you see her hair ew and it's like what
the [ __ ] what are you doing what is this
i saw some of that like this is crazy
but yeah it was stressful though it's
like kind of you can
you can kind of see how it can be funny
but at the time it's like
it's not funny yeah it's funny later
though there was a couple times while i
was getting canceled where i was like
this is
this is pretty funny because they kept
having to uh
quote me and matt like very serious like
new york times
all these very real publications would
quote us like we had just done an
episode about
uh the civil war i grew up near
gettysburg the battle
the battlefield from the civil war and
uh we were talking about female soldiers
that like pretended to be men and we
referred to them as flat-chested [ __ ]
and that was the new york times quoted
us
they referred to them as fat they're
flat-chested [ __ ] and the rebel yale
was
so gay it was like
come on guys yeah well reading that
stuff was actually really
funny there were certain quotes from the
podcast you would read and be like huh
hold up there's like paul jones
he referred to judd apatow as gayer than
isis
everybody knows this is nonsense what
does it even make sense
no do you think the people who end up
writing those articles just haven't been
surrounded by
people who are joking all the time like
but they don't
know what that kind of culture is like
or something no they do they know it
yeah i think it's like class president
energy carried into adulthood where it's
like well i'm the school president
you know maybe they were the people who
were trying to get involved in the
little comedy circles and they weren't
funny
oh that's 90 of them for sure hit the
nail on the head
if you're a comedy journalist yeah you
wanted to do comedy
well it was funny too because when we
were when all this stuff like when uh
you know when the philadelphia comedy
open mic scene got politicized which is
just really funny to think about they
all did every every every scene
simultaneously got politicized like
every every scene i go to they're like
oh yeah that happened here like denver
austin texas like it all happened yeah
well it was also like
you know like we you know you're you're
you're like sitting there with people
you're like friends with them
you see them you're all doing stand-up
together and you know who's reliably
getting laughter from an audience
there's it's like the pecking order
forms itself very apparently and very
kind of openly in that regard
and it was the people who didn't get
laughs who all of a sudden became kind
of like political radicals and it was
just seemed so kind of transparent and
it was just like just annoying it was
just really annoying to deal with and
it's like dude and then like
at any moment if they could kind of like
you know complain themselves into a
position to get some sort of press they
were all over it it seemed like a very
self-serving a lot of it to me at least
seemed a lot of
seem really self-serving and kind of
like agendized under this thing of like
no no i'm actually trying to save the
world but actually i i mean i'll get on
tv if you want me to and it's just like
it's just annoying that doesn't surprise
me at all
no especially when you see that when i
was especially when shane was like shane
got like the absolute like
laser blast of this and i remember i
just was on twitter looking at stuff and
i see people tweeting like
and used to this and i would see their
and like real quick in their
you know they'd have like their little
oh and by the way i'm like a check out
my web series
like people would like jump in on it and
then try to promote themselves through
these things and it was just to me i was
like this is
crazy and i don't think anyone really
says anything because every a lot of
people are like
all doing the same thing like we're
going to kind of like point out we're
going to outrage ourselves into like the
point where we're the ones who get to
have like you know the stuff that we
think we deserve and it's like well just
be good at what you're doing i guess i
don't know it's like trust you would
stand up
like just make people laugh if you can
make a room full of people laugh
reliably
you'll be okay you know yeah that's way
harder than shooting somebody else's
career down though
true yeah true yeah especially when we
gave them so much ammunition
yeah i know we had a lot of ammunition
for them to get
those they got us on a lot of things
yeah when he got hit with that we were
both like
yeah not bad got us one piece you got us
that was it
but yeah it was really the whole thing
the whole it was just us messing around
in a in a room it was like a house like
shane said with we had like renting a
house with like six dudes we were paying
like 200
a month in rent yeah and i couldn't
afford it i had zero dollars yeah it was
like you know we were this
i was coming out of a divorce i i had
just got off an air mattress in my
brother's house
and i moved into a house and uh we were
just messing we were like genuinely
having fun messing
around and doing a podcast and then all
this like you know all these people we
you know we're doing stand-up with got
all like political and we're like like
there's people going other people like i
can't associate
with you anymore like just stuff like
that yeah i see i'd see guys that i was
friends with at like a show and like
start
talking to them and then they'd like be
mean to me and i was like oh i thought
we were friends
i mean i don't care if you want to go
your separate way great but like
why you were laughing at all these jokes
a month ago oh dude yeah i mean there
was literally the place that had us do
digital graffiti which is the one with
like the comedian which we both
obviously participated in we both got
kind of like roasted as well
there was a place that hosted the show
and we're like this is the funny this is
awesome it's so funny and then as soon
as that like the political wind shifted
we're like these guys are bullies
they're mean it's like dude
you used to host this thing you know so
it's just like it's almost one of those
things where
you try to just kind of like keep it
pushing and you know not to get too hung
up on it but it's it's you notice it and
you're like this is annoying
yeah and also i i do want to say i i
hate i don't want to be one of these
guys that's like railing against cancel
culture i'm not one of those
like oh i'm sorry are you triggered that
type of guy i'm not that guy
i don't care i'm not trying to like p i
don't i don't have an agenda to live i'm
not like a free speech guy don't get me
wrong i think it's important but
that's not my identity i'm not this
didn't push me into being political
this didn't when i got canceled i didn't
become like a right-wing guy
i tried very hard not to i stayed away
we'll tell
i mean that was the articles where like
he got hired for by snl because he's
conservative
and it's like no i'm not like
i'm just not yeah that's true that's
something i also admire too
if that were me i would have cashed in i
would have went full just like
right-wing pundit and being like well
actually i'll tell you another thing you
know
that was pretty nice to see now the yeah
the only way to
win i guess is to just keep keep making
stuff and
do well i think if you get bogged down
in the whole like
anti-cancer culture crusade it's it then
that got you now you're out now you're
not doing what you were set out to do
which was
in my case stand-up comedy true i i will
say this too the other thing that really
pumps me up is like
like i'll open up like the patreon or
whatever and like listen even instagram
and get messages from people who are
like
hey like you know i i was go like
someone was talking about like
i lost sight for like three months due
to like some sort of eye condition and
your podcast really made like kind of
helped me laugh my way through it it's
like
that's all that stuff pumps me up it's
like yeah exactly like falling on what
side of a political spirit i genuinely
don't care it's like
hearing people be like hey like someone
in my family died and like it kind of
helped me through that's you know
especially like making people laugh
that's really all you want to do you
know
uh for the most part so
yes yeah that pump that's the kind of
stuff that pumps me up actually that was
kind of fun i asked
i was like dude like that's crazy just
went full ray for like ray charles for
like three months and then got your eye
so it's [ __ ] nuts
and there's people being like i don't
feel safe on you and it's just like
annoying yeah
yeah i had um i had dan crenshaw who's a
congressman on the podcast and he
almost lost both eyes he lost like one
and a half eyes so he can see but
not well out of one eye and i was
reading his book and thinking people
have no
you were not yeah he talked about me in
his book
did i miss that part where were you i
probably don't remember it was uh
the snl he talks about snl oh my god he
did
okay that was you yeah that was a good
book
i didn't read it i heard about it yeah
dude the near blind [ __ ] with us heavy
yeah everybody with poor vision is like
this is the future
okay so did it end up do you think that
you're more
the fact that you basically got
cancelled did that change
how you do comedy do you feel freer now
do you feel more restricted are you
doing everything the same um i for a
little
it gets in your head it definitely gets
in your head like
where it's like oh [ __ ] i don't i didn't
mean to say it like that i know how this
gets misconstrued when you start and
you do think about it but uh stand up
wise it hasn't
changed me too much no i mean you you're
paranoid at first
like when i would go on stage because
there were there were times like
reporters were coming to shows and
recording my set
secretly and then typing it out as if i
was giving a [ __ ] speech
and not joking but uh yeah you get
paranoid about that stuff like i'd look
around the room if i saw somebody like
whisper to each other i'd be like
they're talking about how i'm racist
like it's in your head you're just like
oh everybody here's
they hate me and then you realize that's
just in your head
you just keep going
yeah well good for you that's not easy
most people i would say if you look at
cancel culture not
i think it maybe it's turning around or
maybe that's just the audience i'm in
but
at the beginning everybody apologized
and now maybe you see people who aren't
um but a couple years ago
most people were just straight up
apologizing and then they were gone
right as soon as you apologized
then the people who supported you didn't
respect you and the people who hated you
still hated you so there was no winning
no there is no winning but they a lot of
people that get canceled are already
famous in fact almost all of them
i was getting canceled out of like i was
i live in a
lived in like a hallway in queens and
like getting cancelled
i had nothing before that so like the
only thing
in fact kind of still now the only thing
i'm really known for is getting canceled
and that's it
like at least particularly in comedy
like somebody like kevin hart if he
tweets
they found a tweet from like 2013 where
he was being homophobic
he can still be like yeah well i'm one
of the best communions in the world so
i don't care meanwhile i the only thing
i had was
getting cancelled does that make it i
don't know what i'm
saying yeah you didn't get a chance to
show them proof you got everyone's
conception was just they read a paper
yeah well that guy that's mean yeah it's
i think it helps if you get canceled and
people
are like no i actually know he's funny
with me it was like
all they saw and to this day all they've
seen is just an article that was like
this guy
was using anti-aging and homophobic
slurs
get him out and that's it that's all
they know they don't they can't look
back and be like
like when chappelle chappelle get in
trouble for transphobic jokes
and uh everybody can be like ah shut up
he's funny
yeah i didn't even hear about that yeah
every time he puts out a special
yeah somebody mentions it yeah people
try to cancel chappelle which is very
funny
yeah good luck well half of it too you
know these are these are people
who are writers who are you know trying
to get make a name for themselves so you
just kind of attack you attach yourself
to kind of like a high value target and
you're like i brought them to and it's
it
it's a lot of this is just nonsense even
like the like a lot of the apologies
always sound so pre-packaged and kind of
manufactured
because it's like they literally they're
not apologizing
it's like a person a human being
apologizing to nike
so that they can continue selling
sneakers that's why they sound so like
okay check it off he did it now
we can you know keep selling stuff and
have people you know sell potato chips
and stuff
it's not it's not like a human
interaction it's like i will vow to
do a lot of work and do better and it's
just you know it's just
stupid no one you never talk like that
to anyone in real life
like i will learn i will learn and i
will move forward and no no no no it
just you know
maybe in a hostage situation possibly
but they can even if you have a body of
work or you know you're doing stuff that
if i feel like if you kind of arouse the
ire of people they can still
you know turn you into whatever and they
did it to your dad they like he had like
the maps of meeting course and it like i
remember watching that when we all lived
in that house together
yeah we went to him we went to see him
speak yeah we saw we went
and saw him and it was like i remember i
was like at the point where like again
coming off the divorce
you know doing stand-up at the time it
was just you know not really
i i wasn't definitely i wasn't killing
it in life and uh
and i was like sitting in my room stoned
watching the maps of meeting course when
he's talking about like pinocchio and
like
sounds like the hardest way to watch it
oh my god jesus christ watching a
massive meeting course and
he was talking about like if you [ __ ]
around on pleasure island too much then
you become a donkey and a beast of
burden
as i'm looking at that visual everyone
below me was yelling and
it was wood was downstairs hitting his
foot and going oh
like screaming at three in the morning
while they're playing in jail whoa
and i just was like and i had to get up
in the morning to go paint houses with
my friend and i remember just being like
i'm a beast of burden
i met just going to the salt mine and i
was like no and then i
i watched all those lectures and it was
like genuinely very helpful
yeah i like went to school it freaked me
out so much that i went to social work
school partially to be like i wonder if
he's serious if people are being real
weird at school so i hadn't been for a
while
and i'm like holy [ __ ] he was right but
the uh yeah like it was just like
if you look at maps of meeting all this
stuff it's like a profound body in my
opinion it's like a profound body of
work and then it was like
people like hey here's that guy you like
and it was in the news being like he
hates women and it's like
did you watch his stuff or did you just
read this article because it's not
it's not you know how you know so they
almost can present things however but
you know a comedy special like you're
saying you know people will watch that
if you're like hey
watch 10 hours on personality people are
like i'm good i'm not watching that
so yeah i think you have more of an
uphill but yeah dude it's it's almost
one of those things where
it it acts like a an almost superhuman
amount of like
not self-discipline but you have to
really believe and trust in yourself
to kind of slog through all this stuff
because it it's like again it's like
the major publications being like you
are bad and all the people who read it
being like that guy's bad all right what
else are we doing it's you know
it's unfortunate yeah and when that kind
of thing happens too you have to
you have to kind of entertain the fact
like am i in the wrong
yeah if everybody says i'm in the wrong
then perhaps i could be wrong right you
don't want to be that narcissistic
person who's actually wrong
and just like no i'm the only one in the
world that's right but
in the culture we're in right now
everyone's lying it's a very strange
time or lying to themselves like i can't
imagine people who write those kind of
articles or
the people who decide to hire you and
then say oh no he's a terrible guy like
they're lying somehow like one of the
personas they were
they were showing you was a lie they
might not even know that
no one i think what you said there was
that was one thing that like helped me
get through it was like
i would lay there at night and be like
man am i like am i [ __ ] up
like is this what am i doing like is
this really bad and then i had i kind of
had to thought to myself like they're
not thinking like this
i know the other side isn't lying awake
right now like
am i wrong yeah and that made me feel
better i was like at least i'm
questioning what the [ __ ] going on and
i don't think they are i believe they're
not
yeah no i think you're right man i mean
dude just going to school during that
time was the crate like i was in a
school environment where it was like
you know not like obviously on that
scale but it was the same dynamic
just played with like 12 people in a
classroom where you'd have like
a teacher would ask a somewhat kind of
charged question and it would just be no
one would talk everyone was scared then
you'd have like one lady raise their
hand and be like
well i personally never call the cops on
minorities and you'd be like
first of all where the [ __ ] did that
come from and then you know just be like
ever ever she's like i don't think it's
fair to do that and everyone the
teachers even big well that's really
nice and i'm like
what the [ __ ] what is this why am i well
it's instituted what year was that
uh 2018 i think 2018 2017
19. oh okay 2019 actually it was 2019.
it was a year and a half ago
yeah yeah and it was it was a year and a
half ago man it was just like
it was the most surreal experience about
let's just you would see people in a
room and people come up to me afterwards
and because i told myself i'm like look
just get through the thing i like i just
wanted to kind of get the degree to kind
of like see if i could
down the line work with people in that
capacity and i'm like don't just
don't talk like you know just be quiet
and it was just like
four minutes in a room i would just
raise my hand and be like well actually
in the whole class i'm like man spazz
and i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] damn it but yeah it's uh
it's sad i think people it's more of a
social pressure thing is i think that
what i was trying to say it's like
people are just scared you don't want to
lose your job you don't want to lose
your friends
it's like you know everyone's kind of
walking on like a razor's edge right now
just by being like hey
i think this about this or someone being
like yeah i'm going to chill and wait on
that vaccine i don't feel comfortable
getting it right now
like hey it's kind it was it came out of
nowhere from the people who invented
oxycontin let me chill on that for a
minute just saying you could say like
hey you go get it if you want but like
that carries social implications now
like say that at a dinner party people
are going to freak out at you and it's
like
it's a ration in my opinion i'm like
that's a rational thought but
yeah so you know we are under it's
almost like a totalitarian
like i knew we were i knew we were going
to get the vaccine somehow
yeah i knew this was already demonetized
on youtube
so are you really it's fine we did we
did two this week shane
we got the monetize yeah because we used
the wild west theme song
those bastards oh so did they tell you
why
yeah because we we had a copyright thing
so well youtube can still run ads on
your stuff even if you're demonetized
i think i don't think there's any ad on
my stuff that's hilarious
they didn't tell me anything why did
they demonetize you
um i released a video i got covid in
july
and i i released a video i don't know if
it had anything to do with that but i
released a video about my experience
with covid and a week later
um everything was demonetized but there
were no usually you get
you get a number of strikes or something
this was just like demonetized
what were you saying were you were you
just saying you had mild symptoms or
something because that'll
you're not i think i did say yeah well
no i had like i had kind of flu-like
symptoms for about
two and a half weeks i just described
like what it was
what it was like and then i said well i
think at the end i said
well now that i have antibodies i'm not
getting any vaccine because
i'm immune yeah i think maybe it was
that at the end
i don't know what it was exactly or the
fact that i didn't die from covid
made people angry i don't know you're
actually not allowed to get the vaccine
if you have the antibodies
it it defeats the vaccine it's
it's that's good to know yeah you have
to wait like several months before you
can get the vaccine if you have the
antibodies
because otherwise they'll just attack
the vaccine right away you know
oh true that makes sense oh nice that's
pretty cool
yeah i got it was funny you say that
because i was looking for because i got
i got coven
i have code 19. and uh you're positive i
was positive
and uh i was looking i was like does
anybody
what are the scent like to can i just
find somebody's like
what it was like to have it that's not
i'm in the [ __ ] hospital
like and you can't find it online you
can't hear one person being like cuz i
got it
and what happened to me was i lost my
sense of smell for like
three days and that was it that was the
whole thing and my whole family got it
and they're all right but i couldn't
find that anywhere
the only pieces of information i found
were like yeah you might lose your sense
of smell forever
uh you're gonna get you're gonna get
leveled by this thing
you know laying awake at night like oh
[ __ ] i'm gonna i'm gonna get really sick
dude there were there were people there
were stories they were running early on
about like
uh people getting coveted and waking up
with like different skin color
there were stories of people in asia
waking up like coming out and just being
like
at the end of it coming out like four
shades darker and that was like that's
all the stories they run like
they think that that's what i'm saying i
would i would i would
use that too i wouldn't mind at all but
yeah dude it's like
you know so they're they are just
running the most sensational you know
sensationalistic kind of things and you
know yeah there's no one out be like and
tell you on the news the guy got coveted
and uh
wasn't bad he doesn't know what all the
the fuss is about that was that was kind
of what my video was like i was like no
it was like it was definitely a flu i
definitely had it for about two and a
half weeks and
but i got i gotta i have a toddler of a
three and a half year old so
she gives me things all the time and i
had something horrible
about a year ago that covered me in a
head-to-toe rash and like
i felt like i was gonna die i don't know
what it wasn't jesus measles or anything
but it was
very unpleasant and i was like this
wasn't that whatever that was
was bad um well i mean think of the fact
that
people you know and maybe it's just me
but like there's almost a slight
hesitancy to discuss
your own experience with like a you know
a flu type disease
it's like you know i've had the flu
before i've never i never like felt any
pressure to be like
no it was very serious it was like yeah
it [ __ ] sucked i had the flu it
wasn't like a thing that i would be like
let me not talk about it's not like
you know avoid the the subjects of like
religion politics money and
respiratory infections at dinner part
it's just weird it's weird that that's
like a charged subject now to be like
that wasn't that bad they're like
bastard
yeah i and i i do understand kind of
their argument like if i'm sitting here
like yeah i go
do whatever i want i go out i don't wear
a mask like if i'm saying all this stuff
on a platform and people
are listening to it being like oh i'm
doing that too i mean i guess
i could see how that you know has a
pretty negative effect but
you know i think if you're just telling
the truth about what's happening
like going on and being like i got it it
wasn't bad
i'm not taking away the fact that people
have died from it
and people get crushed by it i'm just
telling you what happened you know if
that
was that exactly yeah no i i know and
that's true too because i
i think i might know someone who did i
don't know you know but it's like
i'm not sure exactly what their issues
were but yeah it's one of those things
like yeah dude obviously like if you
feel like it's a
threat to you obviously stay away from
it it's just again weird that you can't
be like like you know my one cousin had
it was like
snowboarding on the eighth day so it's
like you know i mean
maybe he should have waited two more
days whatever but you know it's like
he's jacked he's pretty hot
true yeah he's like he's tall and hot
yeah all my cousins are like six
four six three i'm [ __ ] shrimp that's
a runt are they funny though
they're pretty funny they're actually of
those yeah they're actually like funny
they can like they're like carpenters
they can like build houses and [ __ ]
they're like the funniest guys i've ever
met
and they're all jacked they're all huge
it's like they're not like
yeah they're all jacked from like labor
yeah
which is the hottest jacked it's not yet
that's what i was gonna say
yeah it's pretty tough it's pretty yeah
but yeah it's one you know it's just
like
it's one of those it's just everyone's
assuming the worst and it's like as if
if you were like i don't know i had it
wasn't that bad that everyone's being
like you were just like you're just like
sending people off to their doom and
it's like you know i understand people
would think like you have to be more
responsible and careful it's like
that's fine but does that like does
being responsible mean just being like
completely silent and kind of
inauthentic to yourself you know
they just by the time you've reached
that point people are like [ __ ] you and
you're like all right
whatever plus b being responsible
doesn't necessarily
mean you should be keeping people inside
their house
right like that's not necessarily the
responsible route
and just because we don't have proper
statistics on the downsides of lockdowns
doesn't mean that if you're going around
saying keep people at home
like keeps keep kids from going to
school it doesn't mean that's the safer
option
we just have this like we're just told
that that's the safer option
it's safer if you don't want to get the
flu but it's not safer if you
you know if you prize your mental health
or you want a social life or
you need money right yeah there was a
guy
we have people listening in australia
and there someone wrote me and they're
they're saying that uh
in australia you can wear you could not
wear a mask if you're jogging
so he said you'll see like businessmen
and people like in like full like
suits who will forget a mask but they'll
just kind of like run
run from the thing it's pretty funny
yeah it's uh yeah it's it's crazy man
this is
certainly bizarre yeah where are you
guys located right now
philadelphia philly i'm in i'm in new
york
oh you're in new york yeah
new york city i'm in new york city yeah
is that i was there in it was there in
october
and i think manhattan's really cool but
it was
kind of sketchy and kind of remind me of
gotham and i was like this is
really sad like what's gonna happen here
it'll it'll it'll be fine it'll once it
rios you think it'll just bounce back as
soon as it opens
i think it has to right it's new york
city i can't imagine it would like
fall into like a dark age dude it was
did you ever see the show the deuce
it was but it was forever it was always
in there true oh yeah
until recently and i think i don't know
i think everywhere is kind of
trending upwards i don't know i don't
know anything about yeah no i think
urban development yeah i think
once once it reopens like and it's it's
going to reopen shortly i think in the
spring
everybody will be like all right we did
it we're done
you think spring i would imagine spring
once it starts getting warmer and people
want to go outside yeah
well unfortunately it's gonna the news
is gonna have to come out and be like
hey guys
you can go outside again and everyone's
like oh sweet thanks awesome
so i was kind of hoping that was just
going
this was like this was not going to
happen but i was hoping that when biden
got elected
covet would just go away i was like they
could i don't even care what they tell
me like
we fixed it like we we handled
everything properly politically and we
got it under control
in the last few weeks and now you guys
are free i was like i don't even care
what they say but
maybe it'll just disappear but that
hasn't happened quite yet yeah they're
they're inching towards it they're
working on that
they hinted to yeah they hinted almost
like the the
new york city governor was like our new
york governor was like
uh yeah we need to reopen now i saw that
it was like you were you were like the
running the parade on the
on the shut it down thing as soon as
yeah whatever no it's true i mean
absolutely that was what happened it was
like you know
and i was following i thought too i was
like as soon as body gets in they're
going to be like all right we're good
and they kind of they they were like
cases
it's looking promising as soon as that
happened they're like oh turns out you
know
the uh the virus was a democrat and it's
uh
changed its tune so yeah it's just it's
crazy man but yeah
i do think the warm way the warm weather
is going to be unresistible man i think
people are going to just go out and
slowly kind of inch their way out and
you know
do their thing yeah i hope so i'm going
stark raving mad here
we're on a stay-at-home mandate kind of
so you're allowed to go out if you're
exercising and they don't
give out tickets like they're not
monitoring you in the street but
it's very very shut down and then
there's talk of
i read in the newspaper there's talk of
a third wave we're in the second wave
now and they're like there's
definitely going to be an even larger
third wave in april and we'll have to
lock down again
we're still in lockdown like we haven't
opened up yet i was like oh no
where do i move to texas maybe true yeah
texas was live rules that's serbia
what serbia was awesome
i was in serbia in the summer for three
months that's when i got
everybody there got covered because
nobody was wearing masks and everything
was open and
the government said kovid kova's gone
kova doesn't exist here
and we were like yay that's great
whatever that means and then we all got
covered
but it was like it was fantastic i
highly recommend belgrade it was awesome
nice sick yeah i'm just gonna keep
walking my dog and doing my thing i mean
i you know
luckily here they don't really you know
they like hint around kind of tickets
but it's kind of like
they don't i don't think they take it
that far they're just like hey get
inside and then you go outside and
you know nobody really cares but yeah
i've never i've never been
confronted at all yeah about like
anybody
telling me to go inside
well that's good yeah because that's
like that's too far
yeah well yeah but australia they were
telling me like you can get like pulled
over ticket it and all that stuff so
they've taken like the full like kind of
government power step but you know back
too i think in canada
those quarantines at night or what is it
quarantine
it's not quarantine that's not the right
word curfew yeah they're curfews at
night and people are most definitely
getting ticketed if they go out unless
they have a dog
what wow what's the what's the what's
the thing at night time
like if people are like do they spread
the fire oh i guess they're like stop
bars and stuff yeah yeah i guess i mean
montreal and things like
pretty heavy partying there but it's i
think it's 8 p.m to 5 a.m
uh you're not allowed out unless you
have a dog and you're in your
a certain like i think it's a kilometer
around your house or something
yeah i mean that's kind of creepy i
don't understand how that's not it's
funny because it's almost
like clich it's become cliche to even be
like i don't know that's kind of weird
like do we all just have a curfew now be
like you're one of those guys it's like
one of those guys doesn't want to be
locked in my house but i guess yeah i
think i think so
it's just weird it's just you know it's
just the whole thing's become strange
yeah well maybe it'll lighten up soon
i'm pumped on it i can't wait i think
it'll be
it was cool too to have the experience
of doing it and like dude like just i
can't i keep thinking about like being
in a restaurant
being crowded and like it being hot
outside and i'm like oh i can't wait for
that it's gonna be awesome
like i used to not really like going
around people that much and now i'm like
i just want to like go out and just
like just run
you can go you can do it yeah yeah
went to a restaurant for dinner in long
island it was do you have places
open oh yeah everything's open oh yeah
just about every i mean now there's a
lot of business there's a lot of
businesses that got shut down
so there's a ton of like just boarded up
restaurants and [ __ ] but yeah
the ones that survived you can just go
for sure and they in new york there's a
thing where it's like it's got to be
outdoor dining and all they've done is
built structure yeah they built
structures it's all inside still
yeah they built giant yeah they did the
same thing here everybody like all the
restaurants that could afford it that
had patios
built just a restaurant outside of the
restaurant with these tents and
filtration systems was like wow that's
intense to keep it warm in the winter
and then everything was shut down here
literally intense
yes damn dude i mean that's that's what
snl picked me for you know stuff like
that
yeah okay okay that'd be funny if you
got fired for an
intense joke they're like we had to let
him go yeah it was terrible
intense i'm gonna use that and i'm not
gonna credit you
that's funny but i'm really really
i don't want that credit
okay um
okay i'm gonna have one more question
and then i'll let you guys go
um do you
how come you guys are funny and i'm
gonna i'm gonna
continue on that for a second
um do you think it's like i've noticed
that people who go through traumatic
experiences
either get completely crushed depending
on the experience or they
end up with a great sense of humor so do
you think that
people need a certain amount of trauma
in their lives to become funny or is it
the groups you surround yourself with or
what can you learn it
people that learn it tend to suck
at being funny there's a lot of
especially in standup you can see guys
that learned the formula
like it was a math problem and they're
like if i say this and if i say this
with this tone
it gets a laugh like which is one way to
i don't know but
i think to go the the trauma thing i
don't know my family
my whole family is funny like uh and
maybe that comes from just generational
trauma
of like just an instilled kind of
dark sense of humor that we all have uh
i don't know
matt what do you think on that yeah i
mean i i think it's uh
yeah i think if you kind of have i would
say like the
the average cookie cutter like i i i
hate kind of like framing it cuz like
yeah
i'm just like a red dark renegade but
it's like yeah i think so like you know
i was one of six kids my dad was one of
ten and like my brothers used to like
put me in truck tires and roll me down a
hill when i was little so it was like
you know i had like i had a bunch of
cousins that would just like
drown us and you know dunk us in a pool
and [ __ ] with us and it's like
yeah for sure i think that i think it
having being kind of like [ __ ] with or
dealing with like massively stressful or
traumatic things kind of force you to
kind of take out maybe a different
perspective on things i guess
um so yeah i think so i think what
shane's saying is true when people like
kind of like watch comedy twice and be
like well if i just go like
people will laugh at that yeah they
usually kind of stink so yeah it's one
i think it's like it's just the family
you're born into and it's it's just kind
of uh
i don't know it's just something that
kind of just pops up it's like being
born with a big dong some people get
them some people don't really
it's like you know i'm funny i don't
have a big dog this is what it is
and i got both but
on that note matt what are you doing
dude you're doing the interview
no that was a good that was a good
ending but i'll definitely wrap it up
um thank you guys so much for coming on
yeah thank you thanks for having us
yeah uh where where can people find you
online uh matt and shane's secret
podcast
give it a listen and then go to our
patreon and help us get money
yep check out matt shane's secret
podcast
psycnol my little pet project
yeah matt's matt's big into psychology
and all that psych
naw and my romance men's team dude
helping the boys i've kind of lost my
mind during cove and started a bunch of
like peer support things so
that's fair whatever you can do to stay
sane right now until things open up
yeah yeah i keep my habits on my
calendar behind me it's it's gotten
pretty bleak over here
i have a morning routine that sounds
kind of conscientious
i i went from i believe so i took it in
2017 where i was at a six i took it
again this year and i'm up to an 11 now
and i think that's because of my my
morning routine so
yeah i think there are really things you
can do to improve that kind of thing
he's also an 11 at lying
we're talking about lions do you think i
sort of got joe
call me a liar on a broadcast dude i
took it twice so i've saw
an improvement in five points so that's
cool yeah pretty popular i think um i've
talked to my dad about this extensively
because people ask if they're low in
conscientiousness how do i
get how do i grow that because some
people are naturally super high
and one of the things you can do is
write a schedule
that you can stick to and then stick to
it and just doing that
really increases productivity and
conscientiousness in people
so morning routine i think is the most
important part of that and i'm a 67 in
neuroticism so i think what i lack in
conscientiousness i feel myself with
anxiety
yeah perfect yeah it all works out yeah
yeah i found out i found out um i've
done those personality tests a bunch and
my neuroticism dropped massively
when i got healthier and
i noticed that my room got dirtier
subsequently
and i was like oh so it wasn't my
orderliness
keeping my room super super clean it was
my neuroticism just like
yeah so that was unpleasant to find out
but what can you do
this is useful yeah exactly exactly try
to channel it
yeah thank you so much man i appreciate
it well thank you guys
have a have a good day
[Music]
you